pollen and i have a hate-hate
relationship
especially mulberry we just do not like
each other at all right
we have high readings for mulberry ash
and now
juniper saying hey i'm going to jump in
the mix too so that's what we're seeing
outside right now
air quality in the moderate category
it's been good lately but the reason why
we're seeing moderate readings is
because the winds have kicked up and
it's blowing around a little bit of dust
and it's blowing around these guys too
all right
it's just that time of the year current
temperatures outside 79 in centennial
hills summerlin 74 for you
81 downtown and north las vegas nice
78 for sunrise manor same goes for green
valley and
whitney ranch 80 in henderson 75 roads
ranch
mountains edge and southern highlands
seven hills currently 79 degrees in the
lakes
at 74. nice and mild too also for a prop
at 76 77 in mesquite 83 in length and
you heard madison she said it's great
outside feels great out there for a live
shot
i don't blame her it's nice outside 84
in death valley so warmer for you out in
inyo county
uh clear skies at least mainly clear
skies for us right now because there are
clouds to the north we took out the
satellite because
we just wanted to show you the radar and
show you how dry it is but there's still
moisture and rainfall in san joaquin
valley changing over to snow in the
sierras if we could just get some of
this to move over to us that'd be great
but unfortunately that's all going to
stay there the low way up on the pacific
northwest but this is what we call the
trough this big dip here in the jet
stream
and this will be swinging through
tonight and also into next week so
as this pushes through we'll see some
other systems sort of the dive down the
back side of this
that we'll see early on next week so we
have several days and several
opportunities for
wind and that includes tomorrow too
gusty winds for tomorrow
sunday breezy monday a little bit of a
lull and then the next one moves in on
tuesday and wednesday giving us more
wind
and breezy winds later on the week we
call the spring wind so it's just that
time of the year
as far as tomorrow goes yes it will be
another gusty day especially midday this
time
and beyond and we'll see those winds
decrease a little more tomorrow night so
that's your forecast
for tomorrow but for tonight prepare for
those gusty winds still still be around
58 degrees partly cloudy skies tomorrow
71
windy and cooler but it'll be sunny
those gusts up to 35
for tomorrow meanwhile your eight on the
eight forecast
does show like we said several days of
wind temperatures will drop to the 60s
on sunday
but we'll be back to those 70s wednesday
however look at that they'll stay in the
mid to
low 70s into late next week too i'll
take it
that's your most accurate forecast we'll
see you guys at nine
christian overview